Robbie is with us Robbie is in st.
George Utah hey Robbie how are you doing
great Dave help yourself better than I
deserve what's up okay so I'm 21 years
old recently married I've been married
now for three months congratulations and
oh thank you
so I'm still about four thousand dollars
in debt I'm a pretty new listener and so
I'm just going to the baby sex but my
question is is what is the best way for
me to say it as I'm a full-time student
and I mean all the listeners I've
listened to and how they're in the
student debt obviously that's the way I
don't want to go into and I mean what's
your advice the best way to they'll all
go and do the school so I don't have to
take out student loans catcher
how much do you like finishing what's
that how much time does it take you to
finish so fortunately I have parents
that are going to help me with my
associates and then after that I want to
be a chiropractor so I have another four
years after that so I mean I got another
six years total okay and you're talking
about spending how much money to become
a chiropractor so I mean I'm looking
between 120 and 180 yeah okay and what
are you made your full-time student now
I'm part-time right now so I'm working
in film with my wife we make about 40 40
a year together okay all right
well the only way I know to do that is
there has to be a dramatic income change
or there has to be some kind of cash
from outside coming at you that would be
like scholarships or something along
those lines I am not personally familiar
I am Not sure it doesn't exist but I'm
not personally familiar with
scholarships for chiropractic I've never
I've never seen them they may exist I
just don't know
and so if I'm in your world if I've got
you know I got to figure out a way to
get my income up or fine
find $180,000 worth of help from
somewhere to keep me from going into
debt to do this right and or it becomes
the problem because here's the issue a
lot of chiropractors make forty five to
sixty thousand dollars a year yeah a lot
of them and so unless you learn
something along the way that allows you
to be one of the chiropractors that
makes 150 a year which they are out
there there is no possible way it is
worth 180 grand so you've got it you've
got to look at that part of the equation
and because for the money you're
spending you could be an MD yeah and
y'all mom ain't real clothes depend on
where you went to school and so forth
so and you know that's something to
study so I want to study what I'm gonna
do when I get out that allows what are
the chiropractors doing that are making
six figures the ones that are winning
because I'm telling you man I in the
last 30 years I've met with a disturbing
number of them that don't make the money
to pay their student loans yeah the ROI
on it is a lot different than other
things because it comes down to how well
you can market how well you can run your
practice the supplements you sell other
things you get involved in inside the
business I mean I know very successful
chiropractors but I know way too many to
suit me that don't make enough money to
have justified its spending that kind of
money so you've got to know that you're
you you're going to be one of those that
makes good money as a result of this and
then you've got to figure out where the
money comes from to go and I wish I had
a good suggestion for you I will tell
you there's no possible way where I in
your shoes that I would go $180,000 in
debt to be a chiropractor not in a
thousand million years never what I do
that and because I don't go in debt
until you go into that for anything but
there's just no possible way I would do
that so you've got to figure out a way
to get this funded if this is your dream
and while you're doing it make sure that
you've got the ability to become one of
the hot producers